[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Welcome
to episode number 33
of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Francesc.
How are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very good.
And you?
MARK MANDEL: Very well.
I feel like I haven't
seen you for a long time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it's been so long since we
recorded the last episode.
Yeah.
So today, we're going to
be talking with someone
that I met during a conference
in Budapest, in Krakow.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And I saw
him wearing a Travis CI
sticker on his bag.
And I thought that it was
because his name was Travis.
And it turns out that he was the
CEO of Travis, Mathias, Mathias
Meyer.
MARK MANDEL: (SARCASTICALLY)
Oh, so no one important.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
no one important.
So he was visiting
San Francisco,
so we decided to
invite him in exchange
of some free food at Google.
And in exchange, he allowed
us to interview him.
He's going to be talking
about all the cool things
they do at Travis
CI, with Continuous
Integration,
Continuous Deployment,
and how they run on
Google Cloud Platform.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Really, really fun thing.
I love talking about testing.
I love talking about that
side of software development.
So super interesting
conversation.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And after that, once we
finish with that interview,
we'll have a question of the
week that is about a topic
that I think we've
covered before.
MARK MANDEL: We've talked
about Kubernetes a few times.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I think we've
covered it once or twice.
So yeah.
We're going to be talking
Kubernetes and what
you do when you have
very specific things
that you want to know.
But before that,
we're going to go
with a cool thing of the week.
And it is a very, very
cool thing of the week,
if you ask me.
MARK MANDEL: Well, yeah.
You've had a chance
to play with this.
So why don't you tell us
about what you've been up to?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is
something that is very cool.
I actually wrote a blog post.
So basically, this thing,
GitHub, where people put code--
MARK MANDEL: I have heard of it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
So we got all the code, which
is a couple terabytes of code,
from GitHub.
And we dumped it onto BigQuery.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And then now,
you can do queries on that.
MARK MANDEL: So it's,
like, all the code,
all the commits, everything?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: All
the code, all the
commits-- I think
all the comments,
I think they have
all the branches.
But it is a crazy
amount of code.
MARK MANDEL: Got it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And so yeah.
I wrote a blog post,
because basically, I
was like, oh, what
can I do with this?
So I wrote a blog
post saying, OK,
what is the most common
file name for Go files?
And what is the most
common packaging?
common-- and one
that was actually kind
of complicated is,
what is the most
important package in Go,
all across GitHub?
And it is really fun,
because, basically, you
can just write some SQL.
And you need to know
SQL a little bit.
Like, I had some
personal issues with it.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But it
was definitely worth it.
And there's actually way more
different articles about it.
So basically, we'll link to the
blog post I wrote, but there's
also one other blog post that
talks about analysis for all
the languages other than Go.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And it's a public data set, so
anyone can play with it, right?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is public.
You can go and play
with it, and try
to find cool things
that you could do.
Best part of it, you can also
run JavaScript on BigQuery
with UDF, User-Defined
Functions, which
means that you can actually
do JavaScript analysis
of the content of the files.
So you can start doing
really cool stuff in there.
MARK MANDEL: Interesting.
So how many times did you find
in the codebase, where it says,
if error does not equal null?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'd
rather not comment.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: [LAUGHS] Great.
So I think that it is time to go
talk with our friend, Mathias.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good.
Let's have a chat.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we're
here with Mathias Meyer.
Hi, Mathias.
MATHIAS MEYER: Hi.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And you're
the CEO of Travis CI.
MATHIAS MEYER: That's right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That is awesome.
Thank you so much for coming.
It is awesome to have
a guest like you.
So before we start talking about
Travis CI and all the things
that you do and everything,
why don't you tell us
a little bit about yourself?
MATHIAS MEYER: OK.
My name is Mathias Meyer.
I'm from Berlin in
Germany, which is where
a big part of our company is.
I'm the CEO of Travis CI,
which is a hosted Continuous
Integration platform.
We have pretty strong
roots in open source.
I think we have a couple of
hundred thousand projects
running on Travis CI, in
particular, open source
projects.
And yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Cool. (SARCASTICALLY)
A couple of hundred thousand,
like nothing, you know.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
No big deal.
Cool.
So what does a day in the life
of Mathias look like at Travis?
MATHIAS MEYER: Oh, that's
an interesting one.
So a couple years
ago, the day looked
like-- there were alerts coming
in and I would respond to them.
That was a couple
of years ago when
our team was still very small.
At this point, our team
is closer to 40 people.
So it's more like figuring out
what the future looks like.
What does the future
of CI look like?
What's the future of
Continuous Delivery look like,
and how does it
impact our product?
And what other things can
we do for open source?
And we also have strong
roots in increasing diversity
in software development
and open source as well,
and it's, you know, a good
mix of these things like lots
of daily business and
operations in the company, lots
of talking to people, lots
of talking to customers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So you mentioned that
Travis CI-- the CI stands
for Continuous Integration.
Why don't you tell
us a little bit
about what is Continuous
Integration for people
that don't know what it is?
MATHIAS MEYER: OK.
So a lot of this goes back
to extreme programming,
where two of the practices
were you build every commit.
Like, everything you check
in is going to be tested.
And the other
practice is-- I forgot
what the other practice was.
Anyway, I'm going to
focus on that one,
because that's the best one.
So Continues Integration
focuses around the idea
that every change you
make to the codebase
is run in an
isolated environment.
You test those changes and
you build, compile something,
and then you run a test
suite that hopefully exists
for this project to make
sure that the change that you
made still works in the bigger
picture of the test suite.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I'm assuming that with
that, basically, what you're
trying to do is to try to get
a build that always builds,
and as soon as someone
messes it up, you just know.
So you don't even need to--
MATHIAS MEYER: Yes, exactly.
You want to be notified
when something happens.
The definition of
Continuous Integration
actually goes a lot
further than that.
Depending on who you ask, it
is also a development practice.
It's a practice of
continuously integrating
your code into trunk.
So it's a very
controversial thing, still,
to make sure that no
changes that you make
will live off the main
trunk for longer than a day.
Extreme programming
had this practice
where, at the end of
the day, if you're not
done with your change,
you delete the code.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh.
MARK MANDEL: Wow. [CHUCKLE]
MATHIAS MEYER: It's very
controversial, still,
at this point.
It was like, we're
now-- I don't know
how many years
post-extreme programming--
15, 20 years, almost.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Something like that.
Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I was thinking extreme
programming-- that
is what Windows XP stands for?
MATHIAS MEYER: No.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Was it? [LAUGHTER]
MATHIAS MEYER: It was, it was.
Yeah.
It was XP for short, but I'm
not sure they have [INAUDIBLE]
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah. [LAUGHTER]
MATHIAS MEYER: I think it goes
back a lot further than that.
No, it was a set of practices
like good development
practices.
One of them that we also
tried to live in the company
is to go home tired
but not exhausted-- you
know, like, to find a
good balance in coding.
You know, you don't want
to spend 12 hours a day
working on code.
You want to give
it your best, say,
at a normal pace
for 8 hours a day.
At the end of the day, your
code is hopefully checked in,
and you just go home
and have a life outside
of work, which is definitely
one of my favorite extreme
programming practices.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So we talked about
Continuous Integration.
How does Travis CI enable you
to do Continuous Integration?
MATHIAS MEYER: So
one of the things
we pride ourselves in is our
easy integration with GitHub.
As I mentioned
before, we have-- I
don't know how many hundred
thousands of open source
projects-- somewhere
around 350,000
at this point
running on Travis CI.
And it's just really
easy to set up.
You sign up with
your GitHub account.
We synchronize all of your
repositories from GitHub,
and you just activate one,
add a file to your code repo,
which is a build definition.
You can customize build steps.
We have a couple of sensible
defaults for common languages.
But you can customize
a build to your liking,
so as soon as you enable it, you
can just start checking code,
and we'll start building it.
So it's just really,
really easy to get started.
Usually, it just takes minutes.
MARK MANDEL: So basically, I can
sit down, take my open source
code, and I don't need to worry
about building infrastructure
around doing my
Continuous Integration.
I can just work on my
project, check it in.
And as soon as I check it
in, it runs all my tests
through the-- I guess it's
a Travis YAML or something?
MATHIAS MEYER: Yes, the file
is called dot Travis YAML,
and it's part of your code repo.
So we give developers the power
to have full control over their
build, which is definitely
something people appreciate.
And also, the build definition
itself is part of the code.
You know?
It's [? version ?]
in the same way,
and you can trace any
changes that you made.
You can trace the
entire history.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And then, as I'm building,
it will notify me
if something breaks?
MATHIAS MEYER: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: I assume then also,
if I get, like, a pull request
or something like
that for my code,
does that also run so I
can see whether it should
be merged in case something bad
happened or anything like that?
MATHIAS MEYER: Yeah.
That's definitely
one of the reasons
why Travis CI exists,
especially in open source.
There was a time
when you got a pull
request to your repository.
I think early on,
in GitHub terms,
it was a [? 4q ?]
or before that,
you'd just get a
patch via e-mail.
MARK MANDEL: I
remember those days.
MATHIAS MEYER: Old,
old, back in the day.
And you would merge
it, and then you
committed to your trunk branch.
You would hopefully have a CI
running, and only then would
you know if it's
actually working--
if that patch is working.
So you would either be happy
because a patch is working,
or you would scream in
agony because now, you
have this patch to
maintain and make sure
that you fix a build
that someone else broke.
And that was one of
the core problems
that Travis tried to solve.
We now have a native
integration with pull requests
that's, like, if
there's a project that's
running and using Travis CI,
and someone sends a pull request
to it, we take the
merge between the branch
it's sent to and the downstream
changes, and test that part.
So we focus, really,
on the integration
between all of them.
So it's like a different kind
of Continuous Integration,
if you will-- and make sure
that the change works together
with wherever the trunk
branch is at the moment.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And I think that that is free,
if you're writing open source?
MATHIAS MEYER: Yeah.
If you're running a
open source project,
the usage is completely
free on Travis CI.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
What if you're not
running open source?
What if you have a private
repo or something like that?
MATHIAS MEYER: If you
have a private repos,
we have a hosted platform for
that, which is a paid platform.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
But you still support it even
if the code is not open source?
MATHIAS MEYER: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Very cool.
No, that sounds really good.
It means also, like, if you're
following that internal pull
request model or you want to
do code reviews internally
when you're building stuff,
then it's all the same.
MATHIAS MEYER: It's a
fairly common model now,
even in companies, to work
like-- you know, GitHub flows.
Basically, a good
name for it-- GitHub
has a good
documentation of this.
You start working
on a future branch,
you start opening
a pull request,
you iterate around
the pull request,
and as soon as a pull
request is updated,
we automatically
rerun the build.
GitHub tracks the merge
between the downstream branch
and the upstream branch for us,
so we can just take that commit
and test it all
the time, whenever
the pull request is updated.
So once you actually
want to merge it,
you're at the point
where you can be certain
that it's going to work
against the master branch
or whatever branch you open
the pull request against.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And I know that
nowadays, I'm not
able to work with
Travis CI or something
similar to that, because
it is very painful when
you change to something.
It was, like, oh,
yeah, I totally
did not break the build.
And, it was, like, oh, I did.
So yeah, it is very good to see
it before you do anything else,
especially pull requests from
people that you might trust.
And all of a sudden,
it was like, oh,
actually that is wrong.
Also, we've been
using it internally
in one of the projects
I'm working on,
where we not only run
tests, but also we
run things like styling, spell
checks, and stuff like that.
Like, yeah, you just
misspelled something
on a comment that
will break the build.
MATHIAS MEYER: Interesting.
People have built interesting
things about this.
Like, there's a conference
that's currently planning it--
I just saw this
yesterday-- who have
a site that they're running
on Travis, the static page.
But part of that page
is a JavaScript file,
which runs on Node.js and
it calculates their budget.
So it's going to fail the build
if the budget is negative.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, nice.
MATHIAS MEYER: And you
know, if the budget is still
positive in the green, it's
just going to succeed the build.
So people have built interesting
things around Travis.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That is very cool.
MATHIAS MEYER: So whenever
you send a pull request,
it says, well, we need to
make this budget adjustment.
And I was, like, no, no.
We don't have enough-- no
money for that anymore.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
You're missing money.
Nice.
So talking about microservices
and stuff like that,
very often, Continuous
Integration comes up.
But also, there's another
thing that comes up very often,
which is Continuous Delivery.
What is the relationship
between both?
MATHIAS MEYER: So it depends
on who you ask, I would say.
Continuous Delivery
is usually associated
with complex pipelines, like
your build runs through stages,
you make a commit, you start,
say, running unit tests,
and then you have maybe a QA
stage that is manually driven,
and then you have
a deployment stage,
which eventually gets your
code either to staging
or to production.
And for me, the difference
between CI and CD--
so Continuous Integration and
Continuous Delivery-- really,
really is rather simple.
CI basically means
you test every commit,
you make sure that any change
that you make still works,
or it could be pushed
into production.
And the Continuous Delivery--
beyond all these pipelines
and the idea of shipping,
Continuous Delivery
is, to me, more simply
the idea that you
could ship your code any time.
Like, the code that
you check in could
be deployed at any moment.
So you adjust your mental model
of how you work around the code
accordingly.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So even if you've just, like,
pushed it to staging for QA--
but then, I mean, that's
basically the same thing,
right?
As long as you've got
a push-button solution
or something like that,
you're just, like,
that's good to go now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I'd like to talk now a
little bit about Travis itself
and how Travis works.
So the first question
is, does Travis
use Continuous
Integration internally?
MATHIAS MEYER: (CHUCKLING) Yes.
Travis CI uses Travis
CI for a lot of things.
MARK MANDEL: Yay,
inception. [LAUGHS]
MATHIAS MEYER: Yeah.
I mean, that's your
first litmus test
for any kind of
infrastructure solution.
Can it maintain itself?
And it's been-- I
mean, it was originally
built as a single, not
multi-tenant, solution.
It was originally
built as something one
of our co-founders
wanted to run on-- he
didn't want to run Jenkins.
He wanted to have something
that runs in Heroku.
And so he started adding a
couple of nice features like
live build [? log ?]
streaming and other stuff.
And based around that,
even the early Travis code
was-- even six years ago,
the early Travis code
was running on itself.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MATHIAS MEYER: And it still is.
Like, we're avid
users, and we also
have a project which is
a canary build system,
which continuously runs
build on Travis to check
the entire system.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice. [CHUCKLE]
MATHIAS MEYER: This is a fairly
active project at this point.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Cool.
And what about
Continuous Delivery?
MATHIAS MEYER: We deploy-- our
general approach is that people
work on feature branches.
We try to make them short-lived.
Some live longer, but the
idea's still that, you know,
trunk or [INAUDIBLE] is
deployed or should be deployable
any time.
It's still one of the
goals, and you know,
there's a good chance it's
going to be deployed any time.
We don't yet count
deploys per day.
It's a fairly popular
metric at this point,
but we're generally very
flexible about people
deploying.
Like, we try to keep
the master branch clean.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So I guess the big question is--
you're here on the Google Cloud
Platform Podcast.
Do you run on Google
Cloud Platform?
MATHIAS MEYER: Yes.
A part of our infrastructure
runs on Google Compute Engine,
and that part also uses
Google Cloud Storage--
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MATHIAS MEYER: --specifically
to run it to use caches.
Like, we have the system
where most projects use
a certain set of dependencies.
It's true for any
kind of language.
Any kind of language has
some package management tool,
and the installation,
depending on the language,
can either be a matter
of seconds or minutes.
So we have this
built-in caching,
where you can
specify a directory
or, say, bundle your
integration as native,
or NPM integration
as well, where
we take the entire set of
dependencies and, you know,
tar it up, simply, and upload
it to Google Cloud Storage,
in this case.
And so in the next
build, it's going
to be pulled down and
extracted, and, you know,
if it's a reasonably good
package management system,
it's just going to detect
that there's always
already something there.
So it's just going to check for
any changes and install those.
And it speeds up
builds significantly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So when you say that you're
running on Google Compute
Engine, does that mean
that for every build task
that you spawn, you spend a
new computed engine instance?
Or how does that work?
MATHIAS MEYER: Yeah.
For builds that run on
that platform, whenever
we get a commit
notification with GitHub,
we go through the process
of creating the build
and scheduling it.
And once we start
executing it, every build
runs in a clean environment.
That was one of the early
differentiators of Travis CI--
that you get a
vanilla environment.
It's going to be restarted
from scratch for every build,
and you can rely on that.
So on Google Compute
Engine, we start up
a new instance for every build.
And one of the things that
we found there was, like, we
get fairly stable boot times
on Google Compute Engine, which
makes it a lot more reliable.
And that was one reason
why we chose it in the end.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Yes.
So have you ever considered
doing some things differently?
Like, instead of running one
new VM per [INAUDIBLE], running
one new container, or
something like that?
MATHIAS MEYER: Yes.
Another part of
our infrastructure
does exactly that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, cool.
MATHIAS MEYER:
That part actually
use Docker to create
the build environment.
And that's just super fast.
Like, I just looked up
the stats for how long
it takes to boot up a
dock container for us.
And I think the 95
percentile of that
is 3.3 seconds for-- so
this is-- when you look
at Travis while you're
committing something,
you, pretty much, see the
build start instantly.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MATHIAS MEYER: If it
goes through the system
within a second, or
something like that,
the Docker container
is just booted up,
and it starts running
almost instantly.
And that part-- we're still
playing around with that.
There is still something missing
on Google Compute Engine that
keeps us from running
that part on there,
but technically, it
could run anywhere.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
That's pretty cool.
So I was curious about
how you're controlling
those Compute Engine instances.
I know we have a series of
APIs, but, like, what does
the lifecycle that look like?
MATHIAS MEYER: So we
hit the API pretty hard.
I'm sorry about that.
So for every build, we send
an API request to create
an instance, and we keep
pulling the API for the status
of that virtual server.
And once it's ready,
the entire build
is executed through
an SSH connection.
So once it's ready, we SSH in.
We compile the build script,
which is uploaded and run
on the virtual server.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
MATHIAS MEYER: That's
pretty much it.
And at the end of the
tests, it's just terminated.
MARK MANDEL: And it's done.
MATHIAS MEYER: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: We're finished.
Sounds good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
was wondering, also,
regarding containers--
since you're
starting a new one every single
time, have you considered
doing things like Kubernetes or
Container Engine or something
like that?
What do you think about those?
MATHIAS MEYER: We've
thought about it.
We just haven't
gotten around to this.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
MATHIAS MEYER: It's
definitely something
we have in the back of
our mind to play around
with that a little bit.
Basically, we have
our own scheduling,
and maybe there are
ways to optimize that.
But we haven't
gotten around to it.
It's definitely something
we have on the radar.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Is that scheduling open
source, by any chance?
MATHIAS MEYER: Most of
Travis CI is open source,
and I think that
part in particular
is-- yes, everything
about that is open source.
Like, the entire
build execution part
and our scheduler, which
is really, really simple,
sounds way fancier
than it really is.
But it is a scheduler, and
all of these components
are open source.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is very good.
We'll put a link to the
repo in the show notes.
There's one more question
that I wanted to ask.
I've been curious about
it for quite a long time.
I assume that there could be a
Travis somewhere in Travis CI.
Why is Travis CI called, Travis?
MATHIAS MEYER: So that
story goes back to-- well,
first of all, people tend to
think that someone in our team
is named, Travis.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, I was expecting.
MATHIAS MEYER: I was called
Travis on multiple occasions,
but it goes back
to Bob the Builder.
MARK MANDEL: Oh.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, wow.
MATHIAS MEYER: Yeah.
That's the response that
usually comes back from that.
Bob has a tractor, and that
tractor's name is Travis.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Wow.
OK.
I really did not
expect that answer.
That's awesome.
MARK MANDEL: We need a picture
of that tractor on the show
notes.
MATHIAS MEYER: The story around
that is, in the early stages,
Travis used a tool
which was called,
Bob, which was just a
simple Ruby script that
was used to run builds.
And so it was Bob and Travis,
just working together.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There you go.
This is Travis.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
No one else can see that,
because we're on a podcast.
But thanks for
showing it. [CHUCKLE]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We'll
put a picture of this.
OK.
I did not know.
I knew, somehow, Bob the
Builder, but not Travis.
MARK MANDEL: I also have to
ask because I can't believe
Francesc hasn't.
What languages do
you use at Travis CI?
MATHIAS MEYER: OK.
So we used to be a
very Ruby-heavy shop,
and a lot of us come from the
Ruby open source community.
So the earliest versions of
Travis were built in Ruby.
And at some point,
for a while, they
ran on JRuby in production.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh.
I have a really
soft spot for JRuby.
MATHIAS MEYER: Yeah.
It's allowed us to scale
up in interesting ways.
Nowadays, most of our
components are just
running on C, Ruby,
and MRI, because it's
less resource-intensive.
And the build execution
part-- so the part
that, you know,
creates instances
and runs the builds-- these
are now mostly written in Go.
We have parts of
our infrastructure
that are still running
on an old JRuby system,
but we're going to replace
that with the Go execution.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
MARK MANDEL: What made you
decide to write stuff in Go?
How did you end up
with that conclusion?
MATHIAS MEYER: That's a
question I can't really answer,
I'm afraid.
MARK MANDEL: Oh. [LAUGHS]
MATHIAS MEYER: It just happened.
That was the team decision,
so I'm [INAUDIBLE].
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's just
because Go is amazing.
Probably.
MATHIAS MEYER: Go is amazing.
MARK MANDEL: If people
want to try Travis CI out,
where can they go?
Where should they go?
What's the best way
of getting started?
MATHIAS MEYER: If you have
an open source project,
simply go to Travis-CI.org,
and, you know,
sign in with your GitHub
account, and get started.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, it is very easy
and is totally worth it,
if you haven't tried it.
I agree.
Well, thank you so much
for taking the time
to come into the Google
office, have lunch,
and chat a little bit with us.
MATHIAS MEYER: My pleasure.
Thank you for having me.
MARK MANDEL: It's been great.
Thank you.
Thank you so much to Mathias
for joining us today,
having a great chat about
Continuous Integration,
Continuous Deployment, and
all sorts of interesting stuff
that's going on at Travis CI.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And the most
interesting part, definitely--
the origin of Travis.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I didn't know that, so that
was very cool to learn.
MARK MANDEL: I found it
really, really cool as well.
So let's have a chat about
the question of the week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
So the question of
the week-- I think
that this one was, someone
asked you this during an event.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So I was in an
event, and someone
was chatting to me about
building custom schedulers
within Kubernetes, and how
they could get involved
with that whole aspect of it.
And at the time, I wasn't
quite sure where to send them.
So I ended up having
to do some research.
So I basically
hunted around, and I
realized that Kubernetes
has a series of what's
called special interest
groups, or SIGs,
that, basically, cover each
different aspect of Kubernetes.
So there's one for scheduling,
there's one for network,
there's one for
scalability, and there's
one for storage, et cetera.
They're really cool.
They've got people
who run them, they
have regular
meetings that happen,
they have Slack channels
dedicated specifically to them.
So if it's something
that you're, like,
oh, I really want
to get involved
with how Kubernetes orders
scales, for example,
or, I really want to dig into
this side of the open source
project, it's a really easy
way to find the right pathway,
the right people to talk to,
and the Google group to get on.
We'll have a link
in the show notes.
It's just a whole page with
[? markdown ?] inside GitHub
that lists all of these so that
you can get involved really,
really easily.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
They look very interesting.
I really like that
there are even
things like federation, which is
very open, a very active topic.
MARK MANDEL: Yup.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
wonder what people
are talking about in there.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I actually think
it's a great way of
running the community
and getting people involved.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Very, very cool.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, Francesc, thank you so
much for coming and joining me
once more.
Are you going to be anywhere
particularly interesting
in the next few weeks?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So by
the time this comes out,
I will be in Denver,
Colorado, and I
will have finished already
my talk at GopherCon,
and I will be a happy Gopher.
MARK MANDEL: I'm sure it
will have been excellent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm sure.
I'm sure.
What could go wrong?
But yeah.
I'll be still hanging
out at GopherCon.
So if, by any chance,
you're a listener
and you're at GopherCon
or anywhere in Denver,
let me know.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
I think, for me, coming up,
I may have some other events
come up beforehand, we'll see.
But in August, I will
definitely be at PAX Dev,
in some capacity.
So if you want to talk
about Cloud and gaming,
just hunt me down or
find me on Twitter.
I will be at that event.
So super excited for that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
Sounds good.
What do you say?
Maybe, since we have not
done it in a while, we--
MARK MANDEL: Ooh, I love it.
Let's do it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --remind people
how to get in touch with us?
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we are on Twitter.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, @GCPPodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We are on Google+.
MARK MANDEL: At +GCPPodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We are on Reddit.
MARK MANDEL: /r/GCPPodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We have a web page.
MARK MANDEL: At
cloud.google.com/podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Or
[INAUDIBLE] same thing.
And we also have an email.
MARK MANDEL: At
hello@GCPPodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And finally, we also
have a channel in the Google
Cloud Platform Slack community.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, the
hashed podcast channel.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There you go.
So yeah, many ways
to contact us,
so no excuse if you have
a question or any kind
of critiques, or you
just want to say, hi,
how are we doing-- feel free.
We're waiting for your messages.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
Well, yet again, thank you so
much for joining me this week,
Francesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: And see
you all next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]